in pipe pour 3 2 1
domo arigato mr. Roboto doh atashi
majide
suck my balls everybody hello everybody
welcome to another episode of genius
brain I have my lovely lovely girlfriend
my partner in crime my jean jacket patch
wearing Lady Muriel song in the house
before language you don't speak at all
the last phrase have suck my balls threw
me off so I'm like a la would you have
ever thought that you would have been
with somebody like me no never ever in
my life I never thought you people
existed at that was just which what do
you would you meet you be long
what do you mean leave me by that funny
attractive oh ok ok
that's not what she thought at all no I
feel like your ideal version of a guy
was actually the complete opposite of me
it was somebody remember when we first
started going on I remember you used to
tell me about I don't know if it was a
slight to me but you could always
mention you know when I was in Taiwan
these guys they would always open the
doors for me
they would just when it when it would
rain they would take off their check and
she'll these guys guys who love to watch
Korean dramas and be that main character
cuz that's the guy that who was that guy
in Taiwan that you were talking about
which one the one that you said was like
super sweet you had a big crush on him
but nothing ever happened
oh yeah he who was he I don't know what
did he do
I don't remember but I remember you told
me he wrote you a letter or something
before you left or what oh no that was
that was in college yeah that was not in
Taiwan nothing
what was that with me which one the
Talon the college got the college guy oh
we're just really good friends and you
know I was really comfortable with him
was like my girlfriend he was like oh my
god yeah that's such a painful thing to
hear as a guy when a guy hears that the
girl that he really really likes that
he's just infatuated with goes yeah
you're like one of my girlfriend's spear
to the hardest well he didn't say
anything he was just like you know one
of the girlfriends we
hung out together and I was really
comfortable with him and he was really
comfortable with me as well I guess but
there was no hints of anything like
there was no moves what do you mean
there was nothing well if there was a
sign then I would have been like oh you
know and it may be something we would
have talked about or something but then
it was until the last minute after we
graduated where I got this present and a
letter and it was it was a really sweet
letter what did the letter say it was
like a poem what would this sweet
[ __ ] move man the poem this was
almost 10 years ago so I don't remember
I just remember it was really sweet and
I was like uh-oh what was the poem about
was it about how beautiful you are was
oh my god it was a it was a song I must
say your eyes are like a glitters he did
not have that kind of accident it's an
enduring message saying letters love
that something like this I remember
there was sunshine and sunshine what
else did he say about you I don't know
but you just you didn't fall for that
why not just weren't attracted to him no
I didn't see him that way and that was
the last time I saw him cuz we just
disappeared off the face of the earth
well we left after college we went back
home and we don't live in the same area
so what well I mean if you guys were
such good friends how come you guys
didn't continue the friendship after
that wasn't he just feel too embarrassed
or what no I mean I still kept in touch
with him but he he on the other hand
didn't and I figured because his heart
was broken I mean I don't know did I
break his heart
maybe he must have liked you for a while
then I think so
cuz how long were you guys friends yeah
he probably liked you for two years and
he finally mustered up enough courage to
finally talk to you about his feelings
the last day before we leave it's like
well nothing's going to happen
yeah well I've known a couple of guys
who did that just because they feel like
this is my last chance but they don't
really think about what happens if that
says no right so in their mind they've
already done so much work to lead up to
the yes that the no is not even a
possibility so when they hear the no
they're not prepared for their whole
world comes crashing down like I bet you
it feels like they're in a cave right
and they see this exit this bright light
and as they're walking towards it
suddenly some it's you with that with
that cartoon detonator with the dynamite
and Musco or maybe he just knew that it
wasn't gonna work out he just had to let
it out somehow yeah yeah I'm probably
not though cuz he wrote you a poem and
it wasn't about and there wasn't him
saying like in the poem it I'm pretty
sure didn't end with and if you say no
I'll still love you forever my little
petunia no it was I'm putting my heart
on the line and if you crush it I'm
gonna die and disappear from the face of
this verse he didn't ask me if I was a
yes or no though of course cuz he little
[ __ ] that's why I no way yeah but that
was not the Taiwan guy Sam oh wait how
did we come around there the Taiwan guy
was I just remember you talked about him
like he was the he was like the epitome
of the nice of a gentleman he was he was
he was such a gentleman he was always
taking care of me you know I mean it but
he liked you too though right I don't
know to be honest I don't know I don't
think so maybe I'm not sure because he
was he was dating someone Oh was he
hmm but it was weird because that girl
was taking care of me very well too and
I didn't know this was like a Taiwanese
thing or I don't know oh so you like the
guy with a with a girl that you knew no
I didn't know her she was new in the
group so we hung out and then later I
found that he was dating someone and
then he she came around to attend this
event and she was taking so many photos
of us no joke five hundred plus 500 plus
I get this huge message and like who is
why is she taking photos of you guys she
was just taking photos of the event and
us and everything but specifically me
and I was weird maybe she was doing
research about the girl that's trying to
take her man away she'd bait LS what
would have happened if you got if you if
you got together with that guy um I
probably would have stayed there he
probably stayed there longer yeah I
probably would have stayed maybe I don't
know cuz my intention wasn't to stay
there forever
but you know it didn't happen for a
reason and I came back home a lot sooner
than I expected for a reason and you
know I feel like your perception of a
what a relationship was or what a guy
was was really skewed when I first met
you like you didn't meet anyone like you
before that's why it was always that
kind of guy that kind of those kind of
guys were always around me bunch of
[ __ ]
sweet sweet guys remember quote of your
day it was what would Dan do no that's
different see for you biz because like
when I first met you um like you had a
your perception of a guy was very
interesting I feel like it was highly
influenced dude - all those Disney
movies that you watched but I really do
feel that way or Korean dramas I was
like Korean dramas and these guys do not
exist Oh like you know you know what I
mean a lot of people are very good at
putting up a front a lot of people and
you know this - so Mary Hill actually
told me the story back in the day or her
mom tried to set her up with this guy
Yeah right and this story was so
interesting because it was very
indicative of a lot of these guys that I
saw at church so in the Korean culture
or I guess I just feel like anything any
type of culture anyways or conservative
conservative culture exactly so that
people are very good at putting upfront
so especially in a church setting if you
went to a Korean Church all these kids
in front of the parents would be the
sweetest angels you've ever met in your
life right so these dudes they would
inside very well so like greet parents I
know you know whatever do all that other
crap and so and their parents would talk
up their children as well because I'm
not gonna talk [ __ ] about their kids
they're gonna say my son Peter Kim he's
going to be a doctor he's studying
really hard he's really handsome and
they try
and it's okay should kill they try they
try to match up their kids with other
kids and so Muriel's mom consistently
try to put Muriel with one of these
Korean kids so these Korean dudes albeit
when you first meet them are very
likeable in the sense of if you look at
their stats yeah they have everything
that you want out of a future son-in-law
but what happens is when they're not in
front of their parents their true colors
show mm-hmm so what what happened when
you went on a game with this guy this
this guy that your mom set you up with
so apparently it's it's through my aunt
actually oh yeah yeah she introduced
this guy to my mom saying that you know
he is a praise band lead he's very
dedicated to church he's a really sweet
guy and you know he got everything else
I don't know he has like a great job
whatever and it'll be perfect for Muriel
and what my mom's like okay let's set
them up so the guy who was supposed to
pick me up at my place
he did his car he brought his I don't
know Toyota or Infiniti car I go inside
there and the first thing I smell a
cigarette really bad cigarette stain
smell and I hate that smell
mm-hmm I hate it so much and it's like
this car that was about to break down
and he was like oh sorry I'm like 30
minutes late
blah blah blah I was like whatever this
is already going down the house for me
he's like so let's go to let's go to
like a bar or something and there's no
bar near my hometown so I was asking him
a bar he's like oh there's this place
called good times good times is this
janky Korean bar that's usually for high
school kids because people can't you
know if you're under it when it's at 21
yeah under 21 you can't go to a bar so
they allow high school kids to go inside
here yeah it's no longer there I think I
think for good reason
yeah but he likes going there so he
asked me to go there and that was my
first time ever going to that place I
hate that place
and we sit down and the first thing he
does he says I'm gonna get out my
cigarette and let's drink and I was so
confused cuz my own told me and my mom
told me that oh this is like this really
sweet you know Christian guy who's
apparently supposed to be an angel
and straight up he tells me he's like
you know I bet you're on told me that
I'm an angel but really I'm not unlike
this oh you trying to be mr. cool guy
and let me tell you some baby you want
all these other people out here saying
that I'm like this goody two-shoes but I
smoke cigarettes
he was an oppa well he was one of those
dudes yeah I like that I was like this
is so fun
I was like two things I hate is that you
first of all smoke I hate that smell and
second you're trying to be this cool but
that I hate yeah it's like I like the
cool but who takes me you know on a hike
or whatever but not cigarette and soju I
hate that yeah and so obviously you
didn't know that and I was just playing
on with him I was like fine whatever you
know I'm help you you know pay for my
lunch it was any time to does it help
that drinking during the day time what
the [ __ ] yeah he was just he was like
that this is what I do I know I'm all
angel at church but really like I also
he was he was actually saying that to
impress you so he was trying to say that
to get you to like I was like yo I know
like I'm actually a bad boy sometimes I
get b-minus is on my test you know
sometimes I even dare to get a c-plus
and I'm like oh ma I don't care I don't
know to be honest at that time I was
like this is not not the type of guy I
want to date but for my own and my mom's
sake I was like I was just have like a
decent lunch with him and then bounce
and so we'd let that went back home and
I told my mom was like I don't like this
guy mm-hmm actually I don't think I even
mentioned it to her because I don't want
her to bug me about it and I feel bad
for my aunt because they don't know who
what kind of guy he is
clearly and I didn't want to ruin that
for people it's like it's none of my
business you know so later on he did
call me back he's like hey let's hang
out again like I guess he liked me so he
kept calling and calling and I got to
the point where I was like I don't want
to hang out with you and he told my aunt
and my mom told my mom and my mom called
me back
angry she was so mad that I would not go
out with them again because she was like
that's the perfect kid yeah she said
this guy is super sweet and nice and
he's an angel and he's a good Christian
guy why wouldn't you go out with him
and I I was so mad at my mom because she
wouldn't listen to me I was like mom I
don't like this guy he's not my type
can you please leave me alone how come
you didn't tell her about the whole
cigarettes and him getting drunk during
the daytime yeah at first I didn't and
then I told her I was like mom you want
to know why I don't like this guy and I
told her the reasons mm-hmm she did not
believe me
oh really she thought I was lying to her
have you talked to her did you tell her
about this recently like yeah just talk
to her about it now and tell her about
it oh oh
a couple years ago it was brought up and
I told my moms like do you remember that
time my mom mom that you almost kicked
me out because of that guy she almost
kicked me out of the house because she
thought I was lying to her house because
you know creepy people they're so
extreme I think she found out later on
that I was telling the truth because she
said right my job I was like good and
then I told her I was like after that
you never asked me to go on a good thing
again and she said yes she did not fight
back she's like my jaw my jaw so I was
really glad course cuz she probably felt
really guilty you know oh the color so
so betrayed of course because it sucks
as a kid when you go through something
that was a terrible experience right and
then I think this old man who's so dark
was he he was in his late 20s I was in
my early 20s okay like so let's just
turn 21 how do we like eight year
difference yeah and he looks so dark and
like you know crows yeah and see that's
the thing too I think like I like just
to go back to what I was saying it sucks
when in that case two for you anyways
you were actually shielding your mom
from this thing because you wanted to
save her from the embarrassment yeah and
then even after you did something like
that and you're doing it from the
goodness of your heart and you finally
confide in her about this horrible
experience that you had she took the
side of the other guy without taking
your side and you're not her yeah and
that that probably hurts you a lot and
it happens a lot I feel like in Asian
families just because sometimes it's
it's not even about you know I should
take the side of my child it's more like
I don't want to look dumb so I think
like that's the instant reaction is they
get hyper defensive you know we do that
too I do it
sometimes even in our relationship and I
was mentioning this before on a JK news
episode where I I'm not sure if you
notice this isn't pretty sure you do
there are times when I'm so damn wrong I
will never say that I'm wrong but like a
guilty dog I just won't look you in the
eye just I start looking off into the
distance look at me I'm looking up at
the ceiling trying to read like all the
design you're stupid you're talking
about the whole time because it might
head on like this I'm so wrong but I
refuse to tell her you and my mom
hairy's I'm telling you [ __ ] ah anyway
but my mom is a great mom
regardless Oh like I'm saying like she
did everything from the goodness of her
heart because she wanted you to find
somebody really nice and the the crappy
thing about that is to like I don't
understand why Korean parents don't get
this like they they purport this thing
like they're so wise they know
everything about the world but they
can't even assess a human being that's
going to their church they see every day
like they don't they don't see it they
they almost refuse to see they're like
in denial my mom actually never met that
guy so I'm wondering if he if she did
see him she would have had a second
thought because she's really she's
pretty good at judging people yeah so
she just heard everything from my on and
my on is an angel she sees everyone as
good people yeah so that doesn't help I
feel like when your mom first met me she
didn't like me I think my mom was
shocked she's like what is this thick
guy I feel like she's loud I don't know
when was the first thing as met at the
funeral your grandma's cool ah I think
she expected somebody different and she
expected somebody with a different
career path so I think that was a shock
for her she never probably never thought
I'd be with a comedian yeah me too
but that was the weird thing too because
I you know I think your mom is a very
sweet person
but your mom is actually very different
from all of our other sisters so your
your your sit your mom's sisters your
odds or way more welcoming than your mom
was so I when I first met your mama is
like oh she doesn't really like
because your odds really like me my
aunts are more family like they have
warmer hearts if that makes sense my mom
is more she's like a cat yeah she's
really sweet she likes me now I mean
it's something happened recently but I
don't know what it is but you know the
last couple times that we hung out she's
been way more open way just just
different yeah you know but he's gotta
warm up to her it only took four years I
only took four hey but we made it I'm
sure she saw that you know us being
together for four years
she realized maybe there is something
you know because I you know a lot of the
times though like anything that I decide
to do or choose she oh it she's always
having a second thought about my
decision and I think you know I'm an
only child but you never brought a boy
home before you know so what you did you
not for my mom for saying yeah did you
bring a boy home to your dad no I
brought boys but she never liked them oh
really
yeah she she would even like girls who
dressed up like boys well you did dress
up like a boy I know I know I know she's
very she's very she's a worried woman
yeah yeah you know it's weird too
because I don't know why I feel like
this but being a Korean American and I
wasn't born here right so and and I kind
of grew up in a very Korean household
but and this could just be an anecdotal
experience that I've had with Korean
people but I feel like Korean people are
very they're very socially conscious in
the sense of they they put up their best
face for everybody else in the world and
that kind of affects how they move in
life right but the problem with that
that I've had with a lot of Korean
people especially even with me dealing
with in business situations with Korean
people they're very good at being
likeable so they're very good at saying
like you know selling themselves yeah
they're really selling themselves mm-hmm
right but what they say to your face
versus what they say behind your back or
what they're going to do tends to be
really different yeah and this is like I
said this is not bashing on Korean
people in general but I think it has to
do culturally if I if I if I try to
think about it culturally speaking and
historically like we come from a very
like like Joe and I were talking about
this how Korea came from the Korean War
wasn't that long long ago for us yeah
right we we we were devastated and
culturally speaking and historically
speaking we've we've had a very very sad
history so we're always fighting to be
on top you know so we're always in like
survival mode and I feel like culturally
that's just a part of us and sometimes
when you're in survival mode you're not
really thinking about the relationships
that you're carrying with people so all
they're thinking about is if I don't get
on top then I'm gonna be on the bottom
or and that's their only mentality that
they have but along that way you burn a
lot of bridges and I've dealt with that
with a lot of Korean people so I'm
thinking like if this is something
that's consistent about my people or the
Korean people that I've been around
there's probably something a little
deeper to this yeah right and it
happened to me quite frequently so I'm
getting to the point where it doesn't
feel like coincidence anymore
it's it's unfortunate because I mean I
used to live in Korea when I was in
elementary mm-hmm years and even back
then it was like maybe in the mid late
90s it was a third-world country like
nothing was happening over there you
know like we didn't have any fashion
there was no fashion no like big
companies I was running around it was
super developing country and then you
know boom ten years later it's like all
of a sudden like Oh Japan is falling
Korean fashion it's crazy it's crazy how
much it changed and it changed so fast
that kind of like you know what's
happening in China is like they're
booming the boom is happening so fast
that the coal truck and the people
cannot catch up to it and I think Korea
had that moment in and it's a lot better
right now but we still have that
something called oak yeah that urge to
like be the best be better you know or
awesome hon you know hon yeah yeah fire
yeah and if we don't do that if we don't
succeed it then you know we feel it
feels like everything or the other
it's everything will be sacrificed in
order to achieve achieve this goal and
sometimes when you do that
it goes back to burning bridges and it
doesn't really matter and that's the sad
part and my dad has gotten burned from a
lot of people like I've told a story
where my dad back in this day um first
of all if I ever see this lady this isin
man I'm gonna kick her
[ __ ] stomach so so we had this
business my parents don't abuse apply
store we still too so I didn't grow up
with a lot of money and when I was
younger we were very very very poor
super poor but after a while the
business started to pick up so I'm
talking about I I remember as a kid like
small little glimpse of glimpses of our
store when we first opened our view
supply store everything was on cardboard
boxes we couldn't even afford the
shelves to put the products on that's
how poor we were so we we just put all
of our stuff displayed on the cardboard
boxes that our supplies came in and I
remember what that store looked like at
that time at a young as a young kid and
then when we started making more money
we started buying shells we started
organizing things to the best that we
could later on there was a store called
Lord Tony's artistic fingers
he's a hair stylist own the whole thing
but he went to jail got back out again
but we took over that store and we
expanded the store out and then Lord
Tony's back now shout to Lord Tony got
it selected I remember since I was a kid
really cool guy but I forgot what he
went to jail for but you know our
business started doing better and then
we opened up a second store and when we
opened up that second store during high
school I had to run that store with my
aunt my uncle and me so after school I
didn't really have much of a high school
like life if I wanted a life I had to
wake up in the middle of night break the
window go out ditch and hang up my
friends super late at night so because I
was working all the time so after school
I would go and run a business
our second business so during this time
my dad um there was a couple things that
happened that he decided that he wanted
to let go that business it was just way
too much work because my dad was going
through seminary school cuz he wanted to
be a pastor as well so he was just
juggling so many things he had to deal
with me my brother two stores and also
going to seminary school in order to get
his master's in divinity or some [ __ ]
like that I get remember decides to give
up the store there was this lady who
owned this hamburger shop I went to our
church and her business was going down
she was crying about it she talked she
confided in my father but she came over
to our house like every Sunday and we we
did worship together her daughter
actually tutored me and my father
decided that hey I'm gonna let go of the
store and because she was crying to my
father
so much about wanting to stay in this
country she can't stay afloat and make
money here she's probably gonna have to
go back to Korea and try to figure out
what she's gonna do over there so my dad
was like okay you know what I'm gonna
let go of this storm and they had such a
good relationship my dad decided to sell
it a store for half of what it was worth
ah so he goes you could run the store we
have it functioning the system's good
just give up that store and then
whatever you're gonna make off of that
give me that money and then you could
take the rest of the store what so my
dad gave her that store for half of what
it was worth maybe even less your mom
was okay with that yeah she was okay
with it they decided so because we were
really close to them so this lady takes
a storm she the moment she takes it
behind my parents back she puts it back
out from market for the original value
that it was worth she takes that money
pockets it and then goes to Korea oh no
yeah doesn't even tell my father about
this lady how is she even oughta do it
she's a snake oh my freaking God nobody
saw a cop I didn't see it coming because
I literally saw this lady at least once
or twice a week and she was so sweet and
so nice to us and then my dad was like
yo what the [ __ ] and she have a family
she has a daughter she went I remember
her daddy went to Emory Emory University
I forgot where they said this but I
supposed to be like a really highly
accredited university but her daughter
I thought her daughter was super sweet
and she tried to to me I was dumb as
[ __ ] didn't really work out but but
that's what her mom did oh my gosh I
like I still remember that till this day
and she's living in Korea doing whatever
now but she literally took that store
sold it flipped it and took the money
moved to Korea so you know for me to
like I did it because of like these type
of experiences I think my father has a
lot of trouble trusting people and he's
very skeptical about relationships and
this isn't just like something that's
happened to him once it's happened to
him two or three times now it's because
my father is a very loving person and a
very kind person so despite all these
stories I tell you about my dad beating
my ass and whatever aside from that kind
of stuff if you look at him as a whole
as a human being he has always tried to
help people out and I credit that to him
you know giving his life to God and so
for him it's about giving constantly but
the problem about giving or the risk
that you take I don't see a problem the
risk that you take about being a given
human being is the fact that you all
have to understand that there's a high
probability that people will not care
about you as much as you care about them
that's facts yeah when you give and give
and give you also have to let go of the
fact that you can't expect that person
to give you that same type of generosity
when you give you give out of the
goodness of your heart not to say that
when bad things happen to you you're not
going to get burned it's going to hurt
cuz for my dad this was somebody that
was a really close family friend like I
remember when they would go visit her at
the store say hi they my parents would
just buy like burgers and fish and chips
from her because that's what they sold
burgers and fish and chips she would my
parents would just buy it for us to eat
and it wasn't my favorite burger on
earth but they did that support they
would buy all these fish and chips oh
man if I see that lady too but you know
what I'm saying and this is the type of
experience that I've had with like just
like certain Korean people you know not
everyone's like that but it is common
cuz you know to be honest that's not the
first time I heard that's that story
yeah I think the way my mom is the way
she is because she has seen that a lot
too and I mean all the churches that we
have attended
that's why she's skeptical when she sees
people who are kind of outside of the
character or who are varied to that
stereotype yeah it's it's hard to
because and once again if you don't know
any Korean people don't don't this is
not for you to use as a basis to judge
people like in my culture yeah are so
good culture and there's also the bad
yeah this is like about this is like
this like five percent yeah that I've
ever met you know and I and I'm kind of
thinking back on it now and it kind of
reminds me of just historically speaking
like how down-and-out we were and how
we're just about we're still in that
survival mode yeah you know trying to
come out on top not not so much just to
[ __ ] people over it's just because
there's this fear that we're gonna beep
organs you know because we didn't grow
up with the lot so if I don't go ahead
and take care of myself who is so you
know I'm trying to find it in my heart
to forgive this like in mind you it's
been about 15 years but just to see my
parents go through that it makes me
think of this late night and I get angry
I get frustrated you know they're you
know God always there's always something
called Karma and God gives you the
reward of what you've done and look at
where you are now
yeah and look where your parents are you
know you could support them your brother
can support them they have two
successful sons
they're in you know think about how I
mean in one way it's so sad that that
mom think about that daughter yeah what
kind of mom she has you know it's like
so unfortunate that her mom had to do
such thing to be in the survival mode
yeah
whereas you guys you know if you guys
were like super poor none of you guys
had that kind of bad idea it sucks too
because even for that girl you know her
daughter she probably doesn't even know
she and she'll never know
right I've even had situations where
this was another different situation but
you know I'm not going to get too into
it but I had a conversation with his
parents basically [ __ ] over my parents
right this was another situation I'll
talk about it another time you know he
was asking hey so how come your parents
don't really like kick it with my
parents anymore like what what happened
like your parents are like super distant
like I don't know what like the
disrespects about no it's like what do
you mean the disrespect he goes cuz
we're cool
we hang on everything's fine but our
parents like whatever my parents invite
your parents out like they never want to
come out to eat I was like well first of
all dude
number one your parents haven't invited
us out to eat or hang out in years
so if they're telling you that that's
not even true I was like and he goes
well that's what my parents say I'll say
bro you don't even talk to your parents
I talked to my mom every day you don't
even speak Korean so what the [ __ ] do
you know
I like second of all do you know why
they stopped talking to each other is
because your parents were stealing money
from my parents yeah you know it's like
some [ __ ] like that and so and it means
like what do you mean and I kind of
broke everything down and he was shocked
you know and he talked to his parents
about it
and they it kind of they didn't really
deny you know so he was like oh [ __ ] I
didn't know I'm not telling you that you
should hate your parents for I don't
know what was going on at that time that
they felt that they had to do that [ __ ]
but you know it's kind of odd that they
would say that we're ignoring them so
why would they go out of their way to
make my parents look bad again it's easy
as well they just don't want to deal
with that shame and I mean I'm in a
place now where I can honestly just try
to look at the bigger picture and say
there there has to be a reason for why
people behave a certain way and for him
it was a shock and he wasn't even an in
denial of it just because the facts were
there like I could tell them like the
only reason why I know this is because
I'm the one who found
yeah and it's none of my business but if
I can find out because my things just
weren't adding up yeah and I and I found
out that this was happening and so it
was they just had a huge falling out you
know and so it's hard for kids to see
their parents in that type of light and
maybe I don't know if I don't know like
it's it's difficult you know and my
father too even with the with the church
that he went to there was a church out
in Korea and I'm sorry in Korea there's
a church out in Sacramento that we
started back in the remember I told you
I wanted to be a youth minister so so
this this story is [ __ ] crazy man so
I wanted to be a youth minister really
bad this is during the time I really
didn't know what I wanted to do I
thought you know and I was still doing
comedy I was still doing music but I was
at this church and it was a church that
my father started up with one of his
close friends
my father didn't take a single dime from
his church and long story short would
actually ended up happening was that
this guy actually stole money from all
the church members and my father was
very skeptical of this guy and he
basically he didn't have any of his like
credentials so my dad they allowed him
to work at the church they liked who the
guy was and he asked my father kept
asking him hey by the way before we
continue can you show us all this stuff
that you did or your credentials or your
or your degrees or whatever that it is
and he just kept dodging it over and
over and over and my dad had a really
bad feeling about it and eventually it
they just came to head where it was the
relationship started becoming really
negative and this is church that my
father started and by the way my dad
didn't take a single dime from this
church because we had our own business
and so he decided to my dad decide to
leave he goes you know what I don't want
to deal with this like this isn't really
worth it for me yeah um well you know
good luck on everything that you're
doing and then I was still working at
the church but my dad told me to still
stay at the church because the kids
needed me so I stayed for another two
years so when I left that church I found
out through ray and Ray's parents told
ray say hey like I heard David left the
church but with on a very bad note
nothing what do you mean I left on a bad
note what do you mean he goes
yeah they said that the the head pastor
said that when you left that church you
and him got into huge argument you
started cursing him out and you left and
I was like wait hold on a second I'll
say who said that oh he said that's what
my parents did and that's what that's
the rumor that was going on at the
church after I left I was like that's
not what happened at all when I left
they got me a cake when I was crying
kids were crying it was it was such an
emotional thing and even after I left
the church weeks he kept calling me
asking me to come back to the church
weeks and the reason why I left is
because I wanted to go into a different
career path I found out that being
working at the church wasn't for me and
on top of that I was doing so much for
the church and their pay me like three
hundred bucks a month and I couldn't
live off of it while I was going to
school while I was doing yeah I couldn't
do it and so I decided to leave and so
he just started talking [ __ ] about me
after I left it just shows how weak
that guy was house he was so weak that
he had to make things up to cover up his
weakness and then behind the scene he
had to break down be the weak guy in
front of you when I found that out I was
so pissed because I gave up so much of
my life to the church even after my
father left I gave my life to that
church and I was so pissed that he would
do that that he would but he would go
out of his way to make myself look bad
make him look good and so you know and
this only goes back to my father saying
where friendship is fresh and business
is business where where is the proof
that you've you've done all this stuff
and he didn't show up with any of that
stuff and so my father after he decided
to leave and I you know I already left
at this point I found out later on Ray
told me that he actually borrowed like
money from the church I forgot what the
money was it was like 30 or 50 K he
bounced and he moved back to Chicago and
he took all the money from the church a
church that was already struggling it's
just [ __ ] trash dude yeah I'm sure
I'm sure karma has gotten to him too but
you know and you know what I met his
daughter [ __ ] his ugly ass daughter
he had the ugliest girl I've ever seen
in my life I don't even care she looked
like her face got ran over by a truck
and was reassembled like a mr. Potato
Head in the wrong way [ __ ] that girl you
know I
in one way I don't this is not like a
Korean thing I think it's just humans oh
this is not a green thing this is just
people grease
humans greed and you know taking
advantage of nice people I mean we have
so many nice and kind people and they're
always getting taken advantage of
because of people like that because they
just want the money or they're scared or
they're they know that they're weak and
they just you know backstab their
friends a my dad because he's had such
terrible experiences with people I think
his his spider senses go up a bit and so
for him he's just going down the
checklist
okay well this guy says he's this person
but he needs to have he can't just say I
have six degrees and whatever blah blah
blah blah I have a master's in divinity
all this other stuff I worked at this
church whatever that cool you could say
that as much as you want show us the
proof and then we'll pay you whatever
you want and he's just like oh I don't
have it oh I don't understand why we
need it yeah your dad's smart he learned
his lessons from it you know exactly but
he's still kind that's the that's the
good part is that usually when people go
through those experiences they become
this you know this mean person they turn
into someone else that they're not but
if you're strong enough then you still
be kind yeah my dad's a very kind person
I think the he's really sweet what I
find to be very sad is that I think that
it's it also kind of made him I don't
know not trusting towards new
relationships and new friendships
because of it because he gave and gave
so much and I don't think my dad the one
thing that he did make a mistake was he
wasn't very smart with his friendships
in terms of how much he gave right and
it's just that it's a double-edged sword
you have to take that risk and then I
think it just kind of wore on my dad's
heart a lot until this day like that's
something that he's he's probably gonna
deal with for the rest of his life
right cuz even for me when I get screwed
over because my father it happened too
much to my dad so much and he warned me
so much about it I was able to dodge a
majority of it and you have a very
different percent even your dad your
dad's very you know he's very you're
very out there you know say what you
want but I think your dad's a little bit
more conservative in terms of that oh
for sure yeah he sees definitely a lot
of what he's lost I think the
personality too for him is just that's
just because of his personality is
harder for him to be out there and
because my mom is very skeptical I'm
more like my mom than I am yeah your
I'm still very outgoing very out there
you know yeah I love your mom my aunt I
love her too much
my mom is very much I'm very much like
my mom like I have all of her great
qualities and all of her bad qualities
too yeah like the temper the being super
loud kind of obnoxious like that's
that's my mom too she's funny yeah she's
super funny caring very caring loves the
cupcake heart I think like my mom and I
are I'm definitely a reflection of my
mother to the max right and it's weird
too because I see it now when I look
back it's uh
I couldn't really see it when I was
younger I couldn't see it like I thought
my mom was really annoying you know when
you're a kid like you just don't want to
be around your parents yeah yeah but
what I found out when I got older was
that I we're twins
yeah and is so funny that I didn't like
somebody that was just like me yeah
we're were exactly the same like even to
this day we still talk every day we're
laughing we're joking on the phone 24/7
and it's like talking to one of my best
friends one of the best traits you have
to really yeah I mean if I think if you
weren't close to your mom you don't
speak Korean it would have been really
hard to use stay with you those are the
big factors I didn't think I was gonna
be with the Korean girl though I didn't
think I was gonna be with a Korean guy
especially a Korean guy who has a huge
temper but you're so ethnocentric build
like I'm surprised you wouldn't think
you would be with a Korean guy you used
you speak Korean so much I do but I I
wanted a guy who wasn't Korean but can
speak Korean like Chinese that's not
possible
yeah it's possible no I met a lot of
people in Taiwan who spoke Korean but
they weren't Korean
yeah but they speak Korean constantly
though don't they no they just learn
just like how I learned other the
language they learned our language yeah
but you speak those languages constantly
I want to find you know someone like you
know do you know Ryan remember Ryan yeah
Jesus someone like that but who could
speak green you know Ryan speaks
Mandarin all the time though is what I'm
saying so how can you find that Korean
guy that's nose cream but doesn't speak
Korean all the time
cuz Ryan he are to be probably speaks
more Mandarin now than this English
probably but he understands both
languages and he understands both
culture yeah so you could that's one of
the more difficult
I don't know but you know I just didn't
have a great experience of Korean guys
so I thought I wouldn't but here we are
with two Koreans yeah this speaks Korean
consistently it's what because my Korean
isn't very good conversationally I think
you understand much better than you
speak so oh for sure that's why I mean
because I don't know how to speak
properly informally very well like I
could talk to my mom very easy yeah you
know just because we're so casual with
it but if I speak to your parents I have
a second guess everything that I'm
saying because I'm like that's not right
that's very disrespectful
whatever same age you know but I thought
that's how my mom talks yeah so and she
doesn't correct me though so you can
practice with me I'm not good at it
either I mean I do the basic stuff I
know a little bit better than you but no
you're Koreans really good if I go out
to like Korean office or business I
would suck yeah but it's still better
than mine if I go into a professional
Korean setting I'm [ __ ] that's why we
should practice Japanese but you know
that's why we practiced together yeah
yeah don't worry little by little you'll
learn it's hard though I think languages
too in order to be really good at in
language like you have to practice it
consistently yo you know and you never
do it you're always so shy about it I
don't understand I do it with you but
you never do it with me you're not
supposed to do it with me though I'm
telling you support you're supposed to
deal with someone who speaks Japanese
when you were living at that apartment
and there was that Japanese family yeah
you had so many opportunities just to
speak Japanese with them and you didn't
do it but they always talk to me you
know it's like one of those things or
it's like you want to use it but you
know that they want to use English it's
one of those no but you could just start
a conversation is like hi like you know
just said if you had a conversation with
them right and you spoke I feel like I
spoke to them on a conversation level
like English wise more than you did
because every time I saw them I talked
to them all the time I talked to the
kids I talked to the girl I and and I
talked to her in Japanese - she would
come up and she'd be like you know what
did she say I don't know she was look in
my room and she'd be like I forgot what
she said see it's like this it's like
you if you don't practice enough you're
confident goes down and then you start
second-guess the frisée it yeah but see
you you just you
just never did it because you were so it
I don't know why you were so embarrassed
I don't know it's that thing you lose
your confidence because before like when
I came straight when I came back from
Taiwan like all I was able to do was
pick Chinese they just come out so
naturally and people will be shocked
like how fluent I was yeah and that's
because I used to use it all the time
but years go by I don't use it and I
can't even say like but see if I even
knew the amount of Japanese that you had
I would try to speak it all the time
that's why even when I go to Korean
restaurants I know these people can
understand English but I also try to
speak Korean as much as I can even
though my Korean is substantially worse
than yours I still try to speak create
as much as I can but for you you're
afraid of looking dumb I don't know what
it is I'm just shy yeah but you got dumb
by like just shy about what though
anybody figure out at Japan
I use it cuz I have to well yeah but I'm
saying you could just take that same
confidence and just put it over here you
had two years I'm an opportunity to
speak with this Japanese family as much
as you could and if you talk to them and
you got to know them and you said hey
like I actually lived in Japan blah blah
and I would love to just you know speak
to you in Japanese if we could just
practice I they would have loved to do
that they were the sweetest family on
earth sweetest well next time with that
opportunity cuz that little girls
supposed to be - I don't know what the
hell she was saying yeah she was are you
Japanese it was so cute and we actually
had a decent conversation you know like
okay I could talk to a lot of kids you
wouldn't even talk to me in Japanese
I'll be like hey let's practice and I
tell you something you're like all this
is too hard and you give up on it it's
because we're doing it after late at
night and you and you know what you
actually recently got a taste of what I
do during the daytime and now you
understand why my brain is fried no no
we do in the daytime I'd be like talking
to you randomly you know in Japanese if
I do it right now unless let's do some
Japanese right now what do you say when
I say it today ma you say we just what
does it start with oh okay d there you
go and then I say thicky mas and you say
what's the game Viki mas when you come
no I said that's you think you must when
I leave yeah and I go shabu shabu this
you did I say oh you better shy you
think your mass is what you say to me
so let's just say you're leaving mmm
what do you say I'm leaving yeah I say
you took my yes and I say did I say that
I should I got every just write this
down I got a right write it down then
constantly yeah packing for us salmon
eat good at this I guess you could use
that sure why not Yesi speak to me in
Japanese right now see this just blanks
out I don't know what you're getting
nervous I don't know what this all I did
blank out you can say I don't know what
to talk about I just black out I know so
that a mmm got a did the knife out of
that mm hi Dada Korea what lunch three
that's so cool shopping Soroka yes hi so
think that what car do some people cut
it yeah hi no but I suppose you go
uh-huh
he says walk out it means understand
uh-huh I'm shopping and shopping there
you know what did I say then Korea what
that shopping Soroka karate chopping
suka I have no idea
see I could I could because I said
Japanese for three years and then try
learning it after if somebody speaks to
me in Japanese I can pick up words I
just don't know the words that combine
to connect things together grammars yeah
so so if somebody says a sentence to me
right I can generally pick up what
they're saying to me yeah you know just
because of whatever three years it gets
stuck for a while that's when you speak
to me in Japanese sometimes I can
respond back to you in English but I
don't know how to respond back I'm like
that too because you don't practice I'm
gonna be flu jab that's why I'm trying
to practice with you because you keep
telling me you're gonna be flowing
Japanese I'm like perfect let's practice
then sheesh night they'll take you 90
time
Benjamin study then she yes
practice practice yeah thank you let's
just study ah Beng cure hmm bang cast
night though
Vincent a keen eye on it so you could do
this okay I am NOT talking to myself
that's perfect talk to yourself anyways
I know I need a partner to talk to I can
only go so far with myself you've
changed a lot
you've changed so much this is a rich
menu would you be so confident in your
Japanese I am confident my Japanese ish
dish it's I mean it's been so many years
even back then when I just met you
that's when I was pretty confident my
Chinese because I use both languages in
Taiwan mhm because I was working the
International Studies yeah but that's
already over five years since yeah five
years is what have a decade the Vedek
you have no practice that's true you
know you know what I just thought about
the other day too
I thought about the when we first
started going out how you really hated
PDA and I'm not I'm not a big PDA person
either but what you considered PDA was
so ridiculous like she wouldn't let me
hold her hand which was so odd oh yeah
you know why why it didn't help the fact
that I lived in a door for so long
PDA is not a thing in Asia we talk my
see dudes hold hands on in in Asia in
Korea like dudes are holding each
other's hands in in Korean Korea is a
little bit more okay with PDA because
couple is a thing yuria but like in
Taiwan or Japan very conservative it's
not a thing it's very you don't see it
much so in even hugging opposite sex is
not a thing there and I had to reserve
that you'd be surprised right but I had
to reserve not hugging people because it
wasn't the thing not not so much anymore
though right in Japan I don't know maybe
not but you were so weird about it so
there was a point where we were going
out it was like in the first couple
months that we were together I actually
dropped her off at the airport
and she went to Taiwan oh no she went to
Korea and she came back two weeks later
and this was like during the infancy of
our relationship and so you know when
you're in the beginning stages you're
like madly in love with this person and
I still am but she flies she comes back
right and then we're supposed to meet up
at this mall or whatever and hang out
and then she was treating me like she's
never met me before you were a stranger
to me she she was treating me like she
never ever met me before
and mind you by this point we've already
had our first kiss we had everything and
she she treated me like a [ __ ]
stranger I was pissed I was pissed
beyond belief I know I thought we were
gonna break up that day okay she started
crying dude she was she was crying cause
she thought was gonna break up with my
god I remember I had this flannel on yay
you so I'm talking about I went to go
see her I went to go for a hug and she
gave me this weird awkward I was like
what the [ __ ] is going on dude we've
been together now for like two months
and so all right cool what we're just
walking around and I wanted to just like
hold her hand as we're walking around
and she just like no we can't do that in
public people are watching and I felt so
disrespected I was like first of all man
you've already kissed what are you
talking about just people people are
staring at us like nobody is staring at
us literally nobody was looking at us I
don't know oh yeah I just came back from
Korea that's right yeah nobody was
looking I don't know what it was like I
just like I don't know you what am I
doing here oh my gosh
yeah and ice at the end was so it was
kind of cute because where we were we
walked outside the mall as I hey I want
to talk to you for a second and I was
like dude like what is going on and
you're treating my treat you're treating
me like you've never met me before and
we've been together now for two months
so what are you doing and I was so upset
and then she starts crying and then the
first thing that she says she goes so
we're breaking up I got even more mad I
was like what are you talking about I
was like this is it relationship I was
like what is going on again I couldn't
figure out what was going on I why
knocking up it was barely an argument
and there's nothing like it's over uh so
I was like are you
I think are we breaking up now man I'm
like jet lag it was such a weird
experience I don't know why you did that
I don't know so long ago that I should
forgot about that oh I remember that
stuff and I still remember the first
time we kissed you punched me in my
chest yeah because I I remember because
I I made you dinner yes right it was
like these roasted root vegetables
dinner
what was it for again oh I don't so when
we first started going out number one
I'm a jokester mind you I haven't been
in in a long term communication so I was
second so I haven't been I hadn't been
in a very long-term committed
relationship and so I was so used to
joking with her on a friendship level
too even though I was really attracted
to her and I didn't want to be put in
the friend zone but for me and a lot of
the girls that I've been with we've
always kept it light-hearted and we
joked a lot so I just didn't realize the
types of jokes that I could do to her
versus my friends because I hadn't been
in that type of relationship in a minute
so whatever the situation was we were in
a car and it was it was a joke where it
started escalating into something that I
shouldn't have been so it was like I
dropped her off and I was I oh you could
leave now she'll die fine I'll leave
I'll get out your car right now I was
like cool get out the car then and she
was fine I well I'm gonna go in my car I
said cool go in your car leave I was
like cool whatever and so after she
leaves I [ __ ] jet off right and I
thought it was the funniest joke ever so
I was cracking up I was like man this
girl's so cool and so I knew I literally
ditched her ass and I left her and I
guess like our date or our date wasn't
done yet but to me I thought that was
the funny joke and so we left and
afterwards I'm at the house chillin I'm
laughing I'm laughing to myself like yo
this girl's so cool and then in Korean
she called me she goes yeah they'll be
just so she was like she was like and
I'll it what what what's going on
she's like basically she says like you
lot have you lost your mind uh
remember that I think yeah they'll be
just saw and that she went off on me and
created she was like you think that's
funny
like what's you just left me in the
middle of our date and I was like oh I
thought the date was done like I thought
we were good I remember I didn't see I
didn't say I was so mad at you on the
way back I was like oh my gosh this guy
can't be he just left me in the middle
of the road and see that's where I'm
like this in this scenario a guy
supposed to come out be like I'm just
kidding or whatever and and give a hug
and then leave or something but no
straight of waiter Jeep I was like this
is yeah but you have a bit of a crazy
side yourself to them I I didn't say
didn't but that was pretty rude so
that's what the makeup dinner was for
which was worth it yeah and we we didn't
even have our first kiss yes they kiss
yet at this point now we met we've
actually been together yeah and so we oh
do you remember this so we were a
caterer
I used to live in Cape Town in this uh
in this it was like a duplex home and
she used to love the plate he's like
jealousy games a lot it was on that same
level of fine I'm gonna leave I'll say
alright go leave I'll see you later bye
and she goes fine I'm leaving it so she
goes I'm gonna put on my shoes and leave
and so she leaves my room and she goes
outside right and I'm like cool I'm not
gonna chase after you I'm not gonna try
I don't I don't want to play those games
if you're gonna leave just leave and she
was like fine okay I'll leave I'm going
and then she gets up and she leaves
right and so I'm like I bet you she
didn't leave and so I and I wasn't gonna
go chase after but she wanted me to go
chase after her because that's the
reason why she said made that statement
that she was gonna leave set because she
thought that I was gonna go chase after
there's gonna be this whole cute thing
but I don't do that type of [ __ ] and so
what I saw and so what I peeped outside
of the room right and I see and I see
you go
I'm peeking outside this room and this
is what I witness this girl this is how
petty she is a human being which is
probably why I love her
she picks up her shoes to pretend that
she left right she opens the front door
and closes it sounds like she left she
takes my shoes and she goes into my
brother's room and hides
I'd like this [ __ ] psychopath
hi and I'm looking out there I'm like
I'm not gonna go chase out there so I go
back in the room I said I come back out
just to peek my head to see what she's
doing and right when I peek my head out
of the room she go like this if you knew
what kind of psychopath is not a
psychopath
got playing on lines got flirting what
you suck at flirt you suck and he
literally saw you pick up your shoes
what was the door clearly I made it very
noticeable that I wasn't really leaving
so you play along with it just like nada
but you go
well Punk don't mine and you just you
know pretend do that for her she got so
mad I should have broke up with you then
then you would have never broken up with
me you would've never broken up with me
not over that Tommy hey maybe tonight
though she night them do you know Tommy
no I don't know I don't know what that
means at all so you you you you've
changed a lot though since we've gotten
since we've been together
so Donnie you too in what ways you're
not as crazy
you're not as regressive you're not hot
temper you're ill you're more chill it's
funny cuz you always tell me chill I
feel like that it was for you you're a
lot more relaxed yeah yeah more relaxed
you know what's funny is that you know
how we were looking at some old photos
mm-hmm not too long ago when you were
bigger yeah you're in time from then and
now are so different you mean what's in
tongue I guess vibe vibe like the yeah
the vibe that you gave up back then you
had a lot
of it looked like you had a lot of anger
mm-hmm surprisingly because I see the
picture of you and now and then like
right now you look relaxed back then you
look you had a lot of anger yeah I think
that maybe that's what my mom saw cuz I
didn't see that back then but looking at
the picture now uh I don't know my yet
you seem like you had a lot of temper I
don't know when I look back on it I
think I was um there was a point where I
was very very very unhappy and I think
it was because there was a lot of
compounding factors when you met me that
was actually a point when I when I first
met you I'm skinnier that now than I was
then hmm
but I was kind of on my fitness ground
when I when I just met you and I
fractured my ankle around that time it
was like super bad and I just couldn't
play any sports and I started gaining
weight there was that and then things
just weren't going the way that I wanted
it to career-wise not to say that I
wasn't successful in other people's eyes
but what I wanted out of life wasn't
happening and there was something that
was missing that's when I started doing
that film but that's when I started
becoming a little happier and then when
that film disappeared is when I got when
I got sad again so you went through this
period where I was just trying to find
myself artistically a lot and I just
wasn't happy with myself
yeah you know and it was just uh it was
just very very difficult just kind of
being in my own skin and I've I don't
like feeling that way I'd like to at
least have a certain goal and work
towards something but I wasn't working
towards anything that was making me
happy so mind you during that time I was
making a lot of money I was very very
well off but they don't like do anything
for me you know but but you remember
that time I was working all the time the
non-starters spread then I was pretty so
thin and I you know when I would go back
to Sacramento I was sleep 1415 hours
straight go to Hawaii I would just knock
out 4050 hours straight yeah and it was
just a very stressful time so what's the
change right now then I don't know I'm
just not making as much money yes don't
need that much money I just don't need
that much money and um I think you know
I talk about this a lot and I don't know
if people understand it but money makes
things easier but for me it doesn't
really make me happy and a lot of people
it may it might seem that way that it
or and it will and to a certain extent
yeah money does make because it could
this because it frees up your time and
that's what money does money equals time
so that's why people equate no money
equals options that's what it is in this
world yeah as like time could be yeah it
gives you options and that's why people
equate happiness with money because I
can remember time when I didn't have
money I didn't have a lot of options
right and I and I always stressed out
about that I was like you know I don't
want to be this poor forever I don't
want to sit sit down and think about
when's my next paycheck coming in can I
pay rent can I do all this other stuff
and when I when that fear disappeared I
thought that buying all these things
that I couldn't have before would make
me happy but when I did that it didn't
really make me happy again so okay well
what the [ __ ] is it then like what what
really makes you happy I'm gonna find
out it's just what makes me happy it's
just working towards something that I
want to work towards without pressure so
like and money was supposed to be the
thing that allowed me to do that but
because I was working so hard to make
that money I didn't have free time yeah
to do the things that I wanted to do so
I was just in this very weird limbo you
know what am I supposed to do it's like
okay and you know if you don't have a
lot of money out there trust me I know
what that is I was broke for a majority
of my life and I'm not that rich right
now but I I now am in a place where I do
have more options and people know I let
go of my Tesla you know I'm not I
haven't bought a new car I'm probably
not gonna get another new car for
another couple years and I'm spending a
lot less but I'm Way happier mm-hmm
so a lot of the stuff that I thought was
gonna bring me joy I let go of that and
it now you could even see it in me like
I have less things but I'm a lot happier
which is very odd you would think that
when you buy more things you you'd smile
a lot more some people it works but it's
not for you yeah for me it's just not
because I know a lot of people who do
buy things and it generally does make
them happy and I'm glad that formula
works for them for me it's not it's not
the same yeah and I'm glad cuz it was a
very hard journey to go through that
with you yeah but you know well why was
it so hard it's like basically you know
in general girl guys are usually just
you know saying
whereas girls have a lot of emotions
going up and down because you know X Y Z
right reasons but I feel like you know
I'm already like this and then you were
extreme so I had to be stable yeah you
know to support us and it was I mean you
know it's tough to see that you going
through such hardship and like being
frustrated you as an artist and trying
to yell go out there and try different
things and come back and feeling like
you failed and the fact that I couldn't
do anything about it but just to be you
know supportive girlfriend and just make
sure that you know you're relaxed when
you're with me or whatnot
it was it was hard because I couldn't do
anything and I think me being angry all
the time too I just hated it because
like I like I remember the first time
you actually ever witnessed me being
angry angry and most of the times I
would never show the side of me at all I
joke about it a lot and you know when I
tell these stories a lot of people don't
believe it but you actually seen it so
the first time she's so glad your mom
was yeah the first time she actually saw
me really pissed off was when you know
things were going right so I actually
put in like 10 grand into this Korean
short film this short series and it
turned out terrible there's a flap it
was a huge flop and it was a big part it
was the fact that I was very
inexperienced the guy that I used he
just he just completely [ __ ] it up and
it was hard it was something that I put
a lot of money and effort in to attend
class a lot of [ __ ] money do you [ __ ]
how rich you are and to meet at that
time 10 grand was everything it was like
yeah like half my big account I saw I
was sad how stressed I was pissed things
just weren't working out the way that it
was supposed to and this guy we were
driving and essentially what was
happening was like I I was driving in
this guy cut me off and he almost pushed
us off the road and so I swerved out the
way I came back in and I wasn't that mad
I just I just kind of gave him the bird
real quick flipping the bird real fast
not even really towards him cuz he was
behind me and you were talking to your
mom on the phone yeah yeah so I didn't
really do much he's just like man dude
[ __ ] this guy just give him a quick bird
and I put it down I didn't like scream
at the guy I did shove it in his face
I'm actually surprised that he saw it
through the tinted back window yeah but
he somehow saw it yeah and so I decided
to play that game
yeah and so he came up to me and mind
you I remember what I was wearing
because we were gonna go to to LACMA and
so I had like this chambray button-up
t-shirt I had this backwards hat flip
thought like you know I actually have to
pick those pictures and so we're uh
we're driving I'm talking to my mom via
bluetooth on in the car and all of a
sudden I hear this engine rev and he
drives up next to me tells me to roll
down my window know right before that
your motors honking right he was honking
endlessly it's just be yeah and that's
how you notice that someone was punking
out you're like what the hell is going
on is it for me or did somebody else and
I was so confused to think who's honking
especially because I didn't think it was
me because that guy almost killed us
right he wasn't paying attention he
almost threw us off the road so I should
be the one that's angry and I wasn't
even mad and so you know we were driving
and the dude it's like screaming and I
just see him pointing pointing pointing
downwards and I'm like what does that
even mean cuz I can't really compute
what's going on because I didn't do
anything wrong so I was like if you
think the wrong guy that's for sure and
you know like being like this fluffy
asian dude I look like a really nice guy
and I am like I don't ever get this
angry and so but mind you I tell these
stories about bright group it wasn't a
great situation and so I was never a
thug but I grew up around a lot of bad
people and if I never fought back with
these human beings like I would get
bullied and beat up all the time so I'm
not saying that I'm a thug but I had to
throw hands as a kid because that that
anger and the worse I was coming out of
your mouth definitely came from
experience because you want to be cool I
think that was straight-up natural yeah
and so this dude is and I kind of roll
down the window and even when I
responded to him the first time it was
very nice I was like what's going on I
was like I wasn't mad yet no you weren't
I mean before the windows came down he
was just like pull over basically he was
making a scene pull over and then that
ticked you off because you're trying to
talk to your mom and have a good time
and then you know basically he he got
your lid off yeah and I just like I
remember like I can't even remember what
I was saying but I felt like I was I
felt like I was like a teenager again
and how is this different
it was it was something like I would
decide yeah what the [ __ ] did you say to
me you wanna come over to me I can't ya
I was just like yo so you want to go you
wanna throw let's go I was like pull
over you
so I slammed my brakes and I went behind
him and I'll scream and pull the [ __ ]
over
and so cuz he told me to pull over I
think the dude was shocked yeah cuz he
thought he could pump me and he was he
was telling me to pull over we stood me
up
and so when I went behind him I went
right back to his side again and I was
like [ __ ] pull over I thought you
wanted to throw Dallas go well I was
moving and so I so he wouldn't pull over
then he tried to jet and leave and so I
started chasing him down and then
finally when the freeway split he got me
because I tended like he was gonna go in
the right lane and he switched out yeah
yeah and then I went off so and that was
so scary for me and I remember that
moment because after I started calming
down and I felt terrible because my mom
was just quite sure why and then all I
remember was hearing her voice and she
was so disappointed she was so
disappointed I felt so bad was that
disappointment I feel like she was
trying to calm me down yeah but she was
disappointed in me because she was I
think she she remembers how I was when I
was a kid and so long getting teary
because like I couldn't tell for those
the cat or oh no it's because like when
I was a kid like she I think she she was
always like scared for my life because I
used to always get in fights and so like
I think like that moment was so scary
because like I was like oh [ __ ] like I'm
kind of turning back into this person
that I don't want to be so all I could
think about in that moment was like
going at this dude
ripping open the door having his face
like right where that door wasn't went
and just slamming it until his skull
broke and that's all I was thinking
about I was like I'm gonna kill this guy
and that's all I could think about is
I'm a way for him to come out and when
he comes out I'm gonna smash his door on
his leg and I'll give a [ __ ] how big he
is no matter how crazy or how much you
know how to fight I'm insane so I'm
gonna smash your skull until your brains
come out and that's all I could think
about and then when I heard my mom's
voice she was so disappointed
kind of like teleported me back to when
I was a kid and I was like and I
promised her that I want to be like that
I have a dude again and then when she
saw it again I was like oh [ __ ] I [ __ ]
and I just sat there and I was like oh
[ __ ] and then you were so scared so I
felt terrible because I scared you I
scared my mom again and I said that this
wasn't the person that I wanted to be
and so like that moment scared me I was
like oh [ __ ] like those were during the
times when my mom literally thought that
I was gonna go to prison like she
thought that I was I would end up in
jail and so when I had that like
reflecting moment all I could think
about was I failed so like I felt so
disappointed
you know and like because like I get sad
a good way I think about that is because
you try so hard not to be a certain
person you know and your parents can do
everything right but it is to no fault
of their own and so because you try not
to be this person for so much and when
you see that person come out again it
makes you feel like a failure and so
that's the only time that was like that
moment where I decided like okay Muriel
will never see this person come out
again and that you really haven't seen
that guy come out since and it's because
it scared you so much and I remember
when it scared you it made me feel
terrible like I felt like trash because
you looked at me and I think that was
the first time I actually thought that
you're gonna leave me I was like oh
she's gonna leave me now because she
actually saw you know how I grew up as a
kid they know I joke a lot you know I'm
a huge jokester and I talk a lot about
like y'all I'm a little [ __ ] and
whatever and I never really am like I'm
not very conversational but growing up
with the people that I did and the
things that I had to do just so I
wouldn't get bullied it wasn't very nice
like you know a lot of people may or may
not believe it but I used to get into a
lot of fistfights and it was just
because like I got tired of getting
bullied like I got tired of people
picking on me all the [ __ ] time and
so the only way for me to do it was just
to throw fists and see what happens if I
ended up dying then I would die [ __ ] it
let's see what happens but it just
turned out that I was just well thank
God I grow to be like a six foot two
asian guy yeah yeah and albeit I didn't
win all these fights but I for sure made
it to the point where people would
understand well you can't just Punk this
dweeby little asian kid with glasses
like out of all the nerds that you're
gonna Punk it's not gonna be that guy
cuz
he's gonna cause you some trouble yeah
and so when I saw that side of me come
out I was just like oh [ __ ] dude like
you you you really haven't grown up like
you're still the same dude and I was
just so disappointed and I was probably
the last time I saw you like that yeah I
haven't done since like I got refused
like I I like probably until recently
with that dude when we were moving in in
Glendale to my new apartment I didn't
see that part but yeah but that was like
and that was like after seven or eight
years and even then it wasn't as bad as
that one time because I all I could
think about was trying to kill that guy
and I just do you think you still have
that I don't think so it's because the
other situation in Glendale was way
worse like that guy was he was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I didn't I didn't punch him
or anything so you know looking back on
those moments it's just like oh [ __ ]
dude like it takes years of just self
thought and reflection and therapy for
you not to be that person and so my mom
saw I I think your mom's a very
intuitive human being because you know I
told her to she goes all you have a lot
of anger and even when she says that
like I feel like I don't because it's
not like how it used to be but I think
your mom can see a lot of the turmoil
that I've dealt with as a kid growing up
as an Asian kid around other people who
used to Punk him a lot and how I deal
with situations and how I demon my
humors angry you know but now I just
deal with this anger by making people
laugh and so when that I think your mom
sense that a lot and she still talks
about to this day she goes you need to
relax you know let things go let it go
move on and so and probably you're like
you know at some point he's like yeah I
know what she's talking about but you
know deep down there are certain things
that needs to be cuz I get scared too
because I think about our future like
when we get married and we have kids and
so I don't want my kids to deal with
problems the way I did and I don't want
them to feel like violence is a solution
for a lot of these things and so when I
get angry it's not like it's not like
when you're a kid in high school and you
kind of tell all your friends about
these conquests that you had when you
beat somebody up and you feel proud of
it I'd never feel proud of that stuff I
feel terrible I feel absolutely terrible
because I don't think about how it makes
me feel I think about how it makes
everybody that I care about feel because
now it's just it's not just my life
something happens to me you're gonna be
worried something happens to me my
parents are worried and so even for my
mom like well like I still remember her
voice on a phone call and I was like oh
[ __ ] like she's so disappointed and so I
just don't want her to feel that way
again so every time I think about that I
get super sad that's how you know that
you've matured hmm I don't want to be an
adult sometimes I wish that that's like
the thing about growing up too you know
what it is ever since that Winnie the
Pooh movie man I'm like super hyper
emotional movie that's true like I you
know when you told me that you cried
after watching that movie I could see it
but I didn't think it was I was kind of
surprised how emotional you got but it's
good it's that you're you know being
more attached to your emotions like
usually you know how you were before you
would block your emotions that's how you
deal with things yeah that's why the
anger came out but now that you're
accepting it you're accepting how other
people feel and I think that part has
grown a lot in our relationship too
thanks for fact that you care more about
how people would feel in terms of like
the actions that you take yeah and I
think that's good and I think that's
where the insan has changed too you know
and I'm really proud of you guys so much
lately it's unreal like everything makes
me cry like I don't know why like every
time I watch something I'm like oh this
is gonna make me cry and I don't even
know why like it's like somebody you
know like when you don't close the
faucet all the way and it just starts
dripping water slowly that's somebody
did it all the way somebody didn't close
it all the way and so everything is
making me cry because now as an adult I
can reflect on things a lot better I can
look back at my actions I can look back
and say oh [ __ ] what I can really
empathize with my parents down like what
they were going through I don't even
have a kid yet I met and I'm at that
point now I'm at that point where I
could look back and say oh [ __ ] this is
probably what my parents were going
through yo you guys incus I think that's
what it is - I've heard that us like
tried it up you know the fact that
you're not as spread thin you could
reflect all a lot of things now I'm
thinking a lot more
and it's weird sometimes I get scared
being by myself because I had to think a
lot and then because when I think a lot
I had to reflect a lot I want to reflect
a lot I think about a lot of the times I
messed up so and it's not regret like I
don't look at it regret because I truly
believe things happen for a reason if I
didn't go through those experiences I
wouldn't be Who I am now so when people
say oh you don't have any regrets it
yeah I don't because what what what's
the whole point of me sitting here
wishing that I could change something
that I did in the past
this happened nothing no matter what I
do what's happened happened hmm
so it doesn't matter do you regret about
that one point I don't regret it because
it happened I don't know what's there to
regret nothing happened
fortunately but what if this something
happened but what if something happened
then hmm what if what if we did get out
the car hmm and then I just got an IB to
let me [ __ ] on that dude hmm
right hmm I wouldn't went to jail would
you have regret it then probably yeah
you know things happen for a reason I
some I'm in jail I'm a little I can't
okay but rape like I can't survive in
jail yeah and glad and you know thank
God nothing did happen because I
wouldn't have known what would have
happened I was early in our early stage
in our relationship so but I'm glad that
you know you have changed in a good way
and I wasn't even that long ago either I
was like maybe three years ago I think
every year is a lot now for us I feel
like moving forward I feel like yeah
like I I think our biggest changes have
happened in the last three or four years
like leaps and bounds it wasn't gradual
a lot of the stuff is like click move
click move click change couldn't change
because before I think things would
transform slowly yeah but things have
been able to I say evolve a lot faster
because we've reached like a certain
level of maturity that we didn't have
before so we don't need to continually
make the same mistakes over and over
then once we recognize it it hits us
really hard and then we try not to do
that again we hit a lot of milestones
together I think we grew up a lot as we
were together
yeah you know maybe that's the reasons
why we did turn through Elsa you know
things happen for a reason I believe in
that truly that God put Sun in places
and bring in you know bring people in
our lives for a reason well that's an
hour and something minutes in oh my god
complete have you ever cried in podcast
I don't think so
you usually make people cry yeah I made
myself cry listening to you yeah I mean
a little kid oh yeah but anyways guys oh
[ __ ] we got an emotional on this plot
because I didn't really expect that I
actually brought her on to make fun of
her today you did plenty of times yeah I
made you cry but uh like she's happy
that she made me cry I mean I like it
when you let your emotions out oh you're
gonna hate it when it comes out too much
I've seen that ha ha ha anyways guys
what an interesting episode of the
genius brain podcast well I will say
this uh you guys can catch us on all
audio platforms yo if you guys had the
time even if you can't watch us on that
on YouTube and you guys can't physically
see it we're on all audio audio
platforms right so we're on spotify cast
box iTunes and if you're on there and
you could give us that five star or that
thumbs up or whatever you can do make
sure that you do it and you know I'm
here to be with you guys on your commute
every day when you need somebody to
listen to or just have a dope
conversation that you guys could peep in
on this is good or cry with this is that
genius brain podcast baby and that's
what this podcast is about a lot of
podcasts I feel kind of focus on guests
and their expertise and that's not what
this is about this is just a podcast
where you could really hear people talk
and real conversations you don't have to
be a celebrity you don't have to be
someone that's special in the public eye
and everybody has a story to tell and
that's what genius brains about and yeah
everybody we'll see you next time
if you want to catch Mariel you could
see her at her Instagram at Mariel
underscore underscore song and you could
also see she's so here's a thing that I
know
she's ready to tell you guys but Muriel
has a very interesting relationship with
her grandmother that passed away and she
if I talked about a grandma she cried
right now but I ain't gonna do it mm-hmm
but you could check her Instagram out
called
was it I could never say all right my
harmony story my underscore harmony
underscore story yeah so Muriel is
actually going to be working on creating
a children's book based off of her the
relationship that she had with the
grandmother so if you want to see her on
that journey check to check that out as
well
and yeah everybody will we'll see you
next time
Jenny peace